nowadays
most people have a smart watch to track
their fitness activities and also health
i've used so many different smart
watches over the years
and knowing my health status on a daily
basis has
helped me to stay on track with my
workouts diet
and also sleep the more data and
knowledge you have in regards to your
own body
the better you can manage your health so
after using so many different smart
watches
what should you look out for when it
comes to choosing the right watch to
monitor your health
what are the functions you need that's
what i'll be sharing
in this video
the first and most important element is
the battery life
i mean wouldn't you get annoyed if your
watch dies midday
or was halfway through your workout
because you've forgotten to charge it
well that has happened to me way too
many times before this
hence this really affects the accuracy
of tracking my health activities
since trying the huawei watch 3 i never
have to worry about this issue anymore
because
this watch can last up to 3 days in
smart mode
and 14 days in ultra long battery life
mode
this is the smart watch with the
strongest battery life
in the industry and good news guys the
huawei watch 3 will be launched in
malaysia
really soon
[Music]
as a fitness enthusiast i want a watch
that can offer me
all day health monitoring and that's
what this watch
does best the huawei watch 3 is based on
the new trusin
4.5 plus heart rate monitoring
technology
which intelligently monitors blood
oxygen saturation
24 7 and takes care of your blood oxygen
health around the clock
so why is it so important for you to
track your blood oxygen levels
when you're engaged in outdoor
activities at different altitudes
by monitoring your blood oxygen
saturation you can assess
your physical condition in real time and
adjust the intensity
of the current fitness the data can let
you understand how your body reacts
to the changing environment when you
work long hours without taking any
breaks
you'll need more oxygen to fill your
brain
however the human body can only take in
limited amount of oxygen
so as a result overworking can cause
dizziness
fatigue poor memory slow response and
even
serious damage to the brain so by
monitoring
your blood oxygen and sleep habits this
will help you to prioritize your health
and take the appropriate breaks when
necessary
if you look at the middle part of the
back of the case the corresponding
sensors are arranged
nearby so when the watch is worn and the
skin is close to the sensor
you can faintly see a red and green
light with huawei's
self-developed hardwood algorithm you
can understand
your heart rate in real time during
exercise
and guide you to exercise in a more
scientific way according to your fitness
goals
at the same time the watch 3 can also
monitor your stress state
in real time and provide breathing
suggestions
by practicing mindful breathing when you
are stressed out
this can help you to manage your
emotions and anxiety
this is a really useful feature for your
mental health
i wear this watch to sleep every night
to monitor my sleep patterns with the
huawei ai technology
it accurately identifies six typical
sleep problems
such as difficulty falling asleep light
sleep
easy waking at night multiple dreams
irregular work
and rest so by viewing the sleep report
you can know in detail
your rem sleep light sleep and deep
sleep
time ratios and intervals for example if
there is too little deep sleep the night
before
you can make adjustments by avoiding
high intensity physical activity
or reduce your caffeine intake closer to
bid time
one thing i really love about this watch
is that it supports more than
100 types of spots including common
spots such as running
spinning weight lifting heat and yoga
as well as niche spots such as
snowboarding
karate horse riding skateboarding and
more
so whatever spot you're into you'll be
able to track it with this watch
and check the exercise data on your
mobile phone so you can view your
exercise time
calories burned heart rate curve heart
rate interval
and more the watch 3 series also
supports
dual gps which provides more accurate
and precise routes for outdoor sports
finally because of the e-sim function
this watch also supports phone
monitoring and sos call for help
now this is an especially important
feature for your elderly parents who
live far away
or even for sports enthusiasts say in
the event that there is a fall detected
the sos function will be turned on and
it will enter into distress
mode the user will then have an option
to select emergency call
i felt but it's okay or i didn't fall
however in the event of an emergency you
can also trigger the
sos emergency help process by pressing
the up button
five times the e-sim can be purchased
through your local operators
in malaysia for me a good smart watch is
beyond recording simple health data
it can also provide the users with
better health management assistance
and that's what i really like about the
huawei watch 3.
it has great battery life provides real
all day health management
as well as detailed analysis reports and
recommendations
on your diet and exercise some of you
might be wondering
do i need to be a huawei mobile phone
user to use this watch
nope you can use this watch no matter
what phone you use
whether it's an iphone or other android
phone
so once you have your far away watch
simply scan the qr code
in the box and download the faraway
health app to connect
it is that simple so let me know in the
comments below how do you track your
health and fitness
and also what are the important features
you look out for
if you find this video to be useful then
do give this video a thumbs up
and share it on with your friends and
get them to start tracking their health
and fitness
don't forget to also hit the subscribe
button and check out a lot more fitness
videos on my youtube channel
all the best